I just want to start with how you guys
are feeling leading into the season
knowing it's the last at least for now
and some heavy storylines that both your
characters are feeling yeah I think how
am I feeling
I feel nothing but gratitude for the
experience and I think when you choose
to be an actor you know that things come
to an end you have to really develop a
thick skin and and your you have to be
very flexible and able to just sort of
accept the business as it is and how
things change so I'm totally grateful
made so many great friends had an
incredible time playing this role and
just season three going deeply into like
who these people are why they are the
way that they are and and and seeing
that on another level was a treat as an
actor to play yeah I'm gonna echo that
grateful yeah it's really rare to be
able to even know that your show is
ending while you're doing it and so that
was really cool that we can make the
most of it and and really enjoy our time
that we had together a really dive into
it and a bit of a victory lap because
they're both battling inner demons and
physical ailments can you talk about the
importance of addressing that and
something that's very real in life yeah
I think you know for myself and playing
Jerry Hogarth this character that has
this really horrendous disease that you
know in in researching it and getting to
know people who have it you know I have
my heart feels so much compassion for
for that journey for people and then you
know playing her and her dealing with it
and watching how how in denial she is at
times and you know she's such a powerful
strong person and so she's just gonna
win and you know she can't win this one
in the way that she wants to win it so
it's always makes for interesting
acting for sure yeah yeah I mean the the
grit is what makes it worthwhile for me
as an actor it's like getting to dive
into the the flaws that make us human
and all of that and the ambition and I
feel like Jerry Hogarth and Malcolm to
Katherine two ends of the spectrum she's
in a very different place he's just kind
of figuring it out and getting it
started and she's looking at the other
end of that same journey so yeah I feel
a wonderful thing for the series is that
for Kristen she came full circle
directing an episode what was it like
having her as your director from
colleague to director sure yeah yeah
yeah Kristen absolutely crushed it as
she does with everything but it was
really the my biggest ally as an actor
was just working with somebody who is an
actor of being her ability to articulate
exactly what it was that she wanted from
me made my job so easy it was just so
yeah just really fun and she was just a
full of joy every single day showing up
to set and brought all of that energy so
yeah yeah she loved it she loved doing
it and you could see it on her I only
got to do one scene with her I was kind
of bummed but you know as her friend and
as a real supporter of her as a human
being and as an artist and as a woman to
see her step into that position and
really really shine
she had this ability and I think I I
really saw how she created the vibe she
set the tone and then she stepped back
and she trusted the actors and she was
so concise and knew exactly how she
wanted to do it and she had the
confidence and and it just was a
pleasure to watch her do it and now to
go mom soon yes
[Music]
you